[Music]
Maksim Chmerkovskiy and Peta Murgatroyd
invited et into their Los Angeles home
on Tuesday to talk about the max Val and
PETA confidential tour kicking off in
March I think I think it's a better way
of showing dance with video graphics and
all the cool stuff that you're gonna see
with the show-stopping show yeah honest
experience and they opened up about
adjusting to newlywed life and
first-time parenting at the same time
we've gone through things you know we've
gone through some stuff that you know
the whole process of having a child is
pretty you know it's pretty big deal but
there's nothing but love and and an
amazing sort of feeling I can't wait to
have another one you know and hopefully
you know be even better for how many of
them do you want three maximum oh I
meant I was gonna be like oh if I could
have million okay maximum how do you
keep the romance alive like how do you
keep the Utah the couples time I think
it's obviously a lot of balance and I
think you have to find that along the
way but you really do you have to make
an effort to get out with your spouse
and do things like you used to do
the couple is launching a special
promotion for their tour the perfect
last minute Valentine's Day surprise
yeah on the 14th Valentine's Day you get
to purchase tickets and you can get two
for one although I have to say if you
decide to go by yourself it's also a
good idea you know I'm saying cuz you're
gonna meet somebody there can you
imagine you met what a story ten years
from now you have kids and stuff hey
mommy daddy how you met we went to that
show and they spoke to our heart we're
sitting across from each other
[Music]